Vulnerability, for instance,
is a real con in itself
because people use vulnerability
to manipulate others.
My brother's in trouble.
He owes them money.
How much do they want?
$350,000.
Well, the film sort of acknowledges
this great truth
that all of us
in some aspect of our lives are not
quite what we seem.
We can't get through life
without being a little deceitful.
You enjoy the show?
You’re a student.
Mhm.
Getting my PhD.
First impressions
are only the tip of the iceberg.
It's important
to really take the time
to get to know
somebody before you start
revealing things about yourself
or inviting them into your home.
Let’s face it,
we’re practically strangers.
Money
can turn people into
their animalistic self
because it is so necessary to survive.
Don’t feel sorry for him.
You can’t cheat an honest man.
That’s why we never
feel sorry for the mark.
These are really smart people,
all of them.
And they require you to be really smart
to follow all their
strategies.
It's people
pretending to be people that they're not.
You really should not judge
a book by its cover.
Behind it,
there's all these other layers
and things and intentions,
and I think maybe it's
about asking ourselves
to be a little bit more vigilant
with what we are susceptible to.
You ready for a test run?